one about the shadow leveling up
sexually Lisa nandy thinks of all this
um senior ministers
bullying civil servants
um you know it's horrendous listening to
the testimony of people who have got
more information than I have but I have
to say that when I was Shadow foreign
secretary opposite Dominic Raab as
foreign secretary I did hear a number of
rumors that this was a pattern of
behavior within the department I think
it's been something of an Open Secret
within Westminster for the last few
years that that there is a problem there
was a problem in the Justice Department
there was a problem in the foreign
office and it was particularly
apparently directed towards women and
this is something that we hear coming
out over and over again
um with this government that there are
accusations of bullying from the Civil
Service
lots of people who are not in positions
of power who feel that they can't speak
openly because there'd be huge
repercussions and these rumors that
swirl around Westminster I I think it's
really damning that Rishi sunak has
appointed him to this pose knowing that
this is potentially an issue and it
comes off the back of Gavin Williamson
who is the former education secretary
who's also faced accusations of bullying
and actually it comes off the back of a
long pattern of you know pretty Patel
who was accused of bullying her own
civil servants by her own civil servants
and there just there seems to be a real
rot at the heart of this government and
it doesn't seem to have shown any signs
of abating under the new prime minister
Dominic Robb uh heartily denies any of
these allegations he's completely
supported by the Prime Minister and
indeed other senior ministers as well
who say they haven't we're witnessed any
bullying by the Deputy Prime Minister
Justice secretary during their
experience with him what is it that
you've heard so the they've been a
a sort of rumor mill around Westminster
for some time that there is a problem
with the way that dominate Rob and other
senior ministers but particularly
Dominic Robb treats their civil servants
I can't substantiate that I haven't I
don't work in the department I haven't
but I think that it's important that
Dominic Rob clears his name and
apparently there have been civil
servants now who've come forward with
official complaints I think it's really
important that the Prime Minister shows
leadership on this issue he said that he
supported Gavin Williamson
in his post completely that he appointed
him to that post knowing that there were
complaints against him and that he
supported him and then within minutes
within hours of uh the the journalists
like UK pushing very very hard
um that decision was reversed and Gavin
Williams and left government I want to
know why Rishi sunak isn't taking these
sorts of allegations really seriously I
want to know why he's not applying a
proper process to all of the ministers
that he appoints and ensuring that those
allegations are investigated fully and I
want to know why he didn't think about
any of these issues before he appointed
people to the post that they're in it is
widely understood in Westminster that
there is that he's appointed most of his
cabinet is because he needed the support
in the conservative party and that he
was rewarding people for supporting him
to be in office if that is the case I
mean that is just absolutely rotten
crazy though isn't it to throw Rotten
Tomatoes
um at high profile uh figures you know
they say tall trees always catch the
most wind and these are ministers who've
been in in government some of them for
12 years impossibly stressful positions
that they're in of course it's stressful
but the point when you're the most
stressed is when you fall back on a very
strong team it's people teams movements
that change things not individuals and
unless you understand that you can't get
things done we live in a democracy you
have to take people with you and you
have to have a team of people who are
working with you in order to persuade
people to take people with you and to
implement and deliver change and if you
can't do that you can't be an effective
Minister we've obviously we're we're at
the current time we're way ahead in the
polls we're not taking any of that for
granted but we are thinking seriously
about what it means to be in government
and I've spent a lot of time over the
last few months with people who have
been in government before particularly
former labor ministers who will tell you
clearly that unless you work with your
team rather than fighting them then you
can't change things and what we're
seeing at the moment is the story
government that is fighting everybody
they're taking on workers who are
struggling to afford a pay rise and
don't know how they're going to put food
on their table for families this winter
they're fighting every single person in
this country and they're fighting their
own Civil Service teams as well that
just seems to me a completely crazy
approach to take at the moment when you
most need to draw on the talents and the
Ambitions of people in every part of the
country although and my newspapers this
morning would suggest that the minimum
wage is going to be increased by at
least 10 percent I mean that's fantastic
news isn't it well it's fantastic news
except that because the Tories crashed
the economy and some interest rates
rising and mortgage payments through the
roof more than 500 pounds on average for
the average family renegotiating their
fixed term mortgage it's hardly touching
the sides and it's right that they
should stop doing no it's right that
they should prioritize so that those
with the broadest shoulders bear the
greatest burden but what we want to see
in this Budget on Thursday is that they
make fairer choices this is the prime
minister don't forget who as Chancellor
spent months at the start of this year
arguing against a windfall tax on the
big energy producers who've made record
profits by their own admission it
changed his mind he changed the strong
leadership isn't it yeah he changed his
mind because he was backed into a corner
but he had to be dragged Kicking and
Screaming to do it and it isn't it a
no-brainer at a time when people are
really struggling with their energy
bills when the boss of shell is saying
please tax us more isn't it a no-brainer
to say We'll tax the profits of the Big
Oil and Gas producers and rather than
making Working Families and he said
that's what he's going to do and we'll
have to wait to hear more details from
Jeremy Hunt the chancellor half past 10
on Thursday morning of course covering
that here on Sky News we're hearing that
um Liz truss will get something like 18
grand for the six weeks that she's been
in Downing Street potentially and that
causes eligible for something like 16
should they take it they I mean they
absolutely shouldn't take it but more
than that MPS are facing a choice today
we've brought a motion to the House of
Commons to say that though Liz trust and
quasi-karting should not be able to
profit from the decisions that they made
in office they bet the house on people's
security and we've seen as a consequence
the economy was crashed mortgage
payments went through the roof and
working people would be paying the price
for many many years to come they should
not be able to take that payment and
this is the chance for Rishi sunak and
the Tories to show whose side they're on
are they on the side of the people who
played fast and loose with family
finances or are they on the side of
people who are going to pay the price
for that for many many years to come
good to see you as always thanks very
much